das wird wirklich ein unglaubliches
schauspiel am himmel werden der
draconiden schauer beschert uns bis zu
100 sternschnuppen pro stunde wie wann
und wo ihr die stern stück machen besten
sehen könnt erfahrt ihr hier bei clixoom
science and fiction
die gibt's täglich spannende science
videos abonniert in channel aktiviert
die glocke nur dann verpasst ihr nichts
die heutige folge moderiert nicht
christoph wie ihr seht sondern ich bin
von astragon stv denn christoph ist
krank gute besserung und euch viel spaß
beim video sternschnuppen schauer
begeistern die menschen schon seit jeher
und das tolle ist man kann genau
berechnen weil man sie sehen wird da sie
jedes jahr zur selben zeit auftreten
aber der reihe nach was ist überhaupt
eine sternschnuppe nicht nur planeten
und zwerg planeten umkreisen die sonne
sondern auch jede menge gesteins und
eisbrocken man spricht von asteroiden
und kometen auf ihrer bahn um die sonne
kann es schon mal vorkommen dass die
erde einen solchen brocken trifft der
asteroid fliegt dann auf die erde und
wird dabei so schnell dass er durch
reibung in der atmosphäre verglüht man
spricht nun von einem meteor oder
umgangssprachlich auch von einer
sternschnuppe
jedes mal wenn ihr in zukunft eine
sternschnuppe sehen könnt ihr euch also
vorstellen dass gerade ein armer
gesteinsbrocken qualvoll über euch
verbrennt die großen brot geschlagen
sogar auf der erde ein
dies nennt man dann meteoriten das
auftreten von sternschnuppen ist für
gewöhnlich aber unregelmäßig und lässt
sich nicht genau vorhersagen
deswegen arbeitet unter anderem auch die
nasa ein abwehrsystem gegen sehr große
meteore da dies potenziell sogar das
gesamte leben auf der erde bedrohen
könnte anders ist das bei sternschnuppen
schauen wie den draconiden diese treten
jedes jahr zur gleichen zeit auf es gibt
nämlich nicht nur verwirrte einzelne
gesteinsbrocken die im sonnensystem
herum fliegen sondern auch ganze
asteoriden felder
meist sind dies hinterlassenschaften von
größe und kometen also riesige
steinbrocken die einsam um die sonne
kreisen
diese brocken lösen sich nach und nach
auf und verteilen ihre
hinterlassenschaften im raum die erde
fliegt dann jedes jahr zur selben zeit
bei ihrem umlauf um die sonne durch
diese hinterlassenschaften
dabei fallen große mengen an kometen
teilchen land auf die erde und tada
einen sternschnuppen schauer ist zu
sehen
anfang oktober durchquert die erde jedes
jahr die hinterlassenschaften des
kometen 21 bewag roubini zimmermann and
diesen sternschnuppen schauer draconiden
daher von der erde aus gesehen scheinbar
aus dem sternbild drache auf lateinisch
zu entsprechen scheint in wirklichkeit
sind die sterne dieses sternbild
natürlich lichtjahre entfernt und haben
mit den sternschnuppen die wir sehen nix
am hut
man verwendet das nur als richtungs
bezeichnung wie viele sternschnuppen man
sehen kann ist von jahr zu jahr
unterschiedlich 2011 das war ein richtig
gutes jahr für stern schlucken konnte
man bis zu 400 draconiden schnuppen pro
stunde bewundern
dieses jahr wird es nicht ganz so krass
aber für einige dutzend sternschnuppen
pro stunde wird es hoffentlich immer
noch reichen wenn ihr die draconiden
sehen wollt steht in den nächsten tagen
früh auf und schaut mal in den himmel
den höhepunkt erreichen sie haben achten
oktober übrigens mein geburtstag bis zum
10 oktober die nächsten nächte werden
also echt beeindruckend und das
wichtigste bei sternschnuppen ist ja
dass man sich etwas wünschen kann und
ich wünsche mir jetzt dass ihr wenn ihr
lust habt meinen schädel astro kommis tv
abonniert mein ziel ist es dieses jahr
noch 15.000 abos zu knacken
helft mir mal entlasten aber da und
falls ihr wissen wollt was für gefahren
im weltraum noch lauern neben
sternschnuppen zb aliens gammablitze
dann schaut euch mal dieses video von
mir an würde mich freuen
ansonsten sehen wir uns im nächsten
video bleibt immer neugierig und macht's
gut